all defensive first team giannis another
the
defensive player of the year anthony
davis rudy gobert
marcus smart ben simmons makes first
team
defense for the first time second team
brooke lopez eric bledsoe kawhi leonard
bam adebayo
and patrick beverly
and it is our pleasure to welcome to the
show marcus smart of the boston celtics
second year in a row your first team
all defense marcus congratulations on
that
thank you guys feels great and here's a
question for you
are great defenders born or made
great defenders are born but you can
become a great defender by
you know just putting in that work you
know um it doesn't
anybody can be one it is really just
depending on how bad you want it
all effort really when you uh when you
figure out
you can guard little guys ones
twos threes i'm not sure about the fours
cause i ought to
post you up down low what what is that
what is it to you what's your biggest
challenge
are those three positions uh my
challenge is probably guarding those
little guards just because
you know i'm six three and you know most
of the guards i'm guarding are below six
foot
and they're just running around all day
every day they just continue to go so
that's really my challenge you know i
really have to lock in more than
probably i do
on the bigger guys because at when i'm
guarding those three guys uh
my speed because of me being my size
becomes uh
my my greatest asset but when i'm
growing those little guys they got all
the speed towards me so i just have to
be able to put my body on them
throughout the whole game and wear him
down
when you're guarding a guy let's just
say he's averaging 30 35 points
do you say to yourself okay tonight i'm
holding the 10 to 12 points as a sign of
good defense
what's your mentality guarding a guy
that's a prolific mf scorer
uh definitely you know when you got a
guy that's you know uh
like you said a prolific score it's
tough to really just say that you're
gonna stop him you know
your best bet is trying to contain them
and make everything tough for them so
you know got a score in 30 35 you know
you could hold into 10 to 12 15 points
you did your job
well just marcus just so you know mf
means uh most frequent
for strat shack so you just if you if
you didn't know
but um my question is this you
obviously checked actually about the
30-point scores
charles taught you the multiple
positions i always thought there was a
game plan
you know defensively that your team has
but then what is your internal game plan
like like for me
as a point guard i said okay i'm gonna
push the ball from free throw line to
free-throw line as fast as i can
i'm gonna pick up my defender here like
what are the three things that you say
every night
i'm bringing this defensively
uh so what's funny is you know a couple
years like two years ago i actually went
out
uh to colorado and and denver and worked
with chauncey phillips a little bit so
you know really just changed my mindset
of you know we got a lot of great guys
on this team who can score the ball
and that's the point guard my job is to
get those guys the ball and knock down
those open shots and if all
all of us fails if that's not working
those guys not making shots then i have
to
become that aggressive scorer or
whatever i need to do on the offensive
end and on the defensive end just
continue to beat me
as a point guard every night i just come
out like i said just get those guys the
ball
and just do everything i can to help my
team win
listen obviously we're here because
you're a defensive player but the other
night you went ballistic
from three-point land what you can see
your teammates were happy what happened
for you
what's it like when you're in the zone
like that
oh man being in that type of zone is
different it's a different feeling
um it's literally you in the gym by
yourself
stuff that you've been practicing and
doing your whole career just in the gym
getting up extra shots
getting the shots watching the ball go
through the hoop man as we all know
who's been in that zone before that
once you get in there that hoop becomes
a lot bigger it's like shooting into the
ocean
uh marcus i got to ask you the um
because you did test positive at one
point for covet
what can you tell us about um
how that how it made you feel and you
know how
you know what effect did it have on you
because i know you said hey look
take this thing seriously folks
um yeah for me when i tested positive
for covet
um you know i was one of the ones
blessed enough to to
to not have any symptoms and actually
you know um
be okay um it was it was frustrating the
fact that you know
my family members were worried it was
that extra stress and worry that you put
on the dear loved ones
when you find out something like that
and uh not really understanding to the
full extent of what this
is or what's going to happen long term
short term
um so adding that that frustration on
you while you know
um trying to to keep a positive face in
and things like that uh but it is
serious
and it's something that you know i would
rather be safe than sorry
and you know like i said i was one of
the lucky ones where i didn't have any
symptoms
and you know my tests came back once i
negative
everything came back that's okay for me
with my health and everything so
but it is something that people need to
take seriously we appreciate having you
on the show tonight we congratulate you
once again on being first team all
defensive for the second straight year
marcus smart joining us from the bubble
in orlando
and we will be back to wrap things up
our